[APPLAUSE]
CAROLINE WEBB: Thank you.
Thank you.
What a lovely welcome.
Thanks a lot.
So I have to start by admitting
that, despite the topic
of my book, not every day in
my past has been a good day.
And in fact, as I stand here
in front of you in heels,
I'm actually reminded of a time
that was early in my career
at McKinsey as a consultant.
And it was the very
first time that I
was being allowed to present to
the board, which was exciting
and also nerve-racking.
And so I was nervous.
And mostly, I was deciding
that I would project gravitas
and presence into the room by
striding about as boldly as I
could, much like this.
And I was, in my
mind, owning the room.
I'd even looked down
and checked the cabling
to make sure I wasn't
going to trip over.
So here I am owning the room.
And then something happened
which I had not planned for.
I took, perhaps, one
of my boldest steps
into the middle of the room.
Some of you know what happened.
Then I heard this crack.
And it turns out
that it is actually
entirely possible for a
heel to shear completely
off a shoe, which is then,
obviously, what happened.
So as I'm lying on the
floor, it turns out
that it was pretty impossible
to project any further gravitas
or presence into the room.
So there are things
we can't control.
There are wardrobe malfunctions.
There are technology
glitches, miscommunications,
difficult colleagues,
difficult deadlines.
Of course there are
things we can't control.
But I've always been
interested in something
I call the philosophy of
realistic optimism, which
is not to say that
everything is awesome
and everything is amazing
if you just say it enough,
but to look harder
at the constraints,
look them in the eye and
say, OK, what can we do
around them and through them?
Where's our wiggle room?
What's our scope
for action here?
And for me, the toolbox
that I've turned to
is behavioral science.
Because we only have to
understand a little of how
the brain works and
why we behave and think
and feel as we do and why
other people think and feel
and behave as they
do to see that we've
got a lot more control over
things that actually seem quite
random from day to day, but
aren't, things that seem
fixed in our lives that
we have to adapt to,
but we actually can control
to a certain extent.
So I'd like to tell three
stories today about things
that we think of as fixed
that we have to adapt to.
I'm going to talk about
reality, the big one.
How can we change the
reality we experience?
I'm going to talk about time.
How do we get more
time in the day?
And I'm going to talk
about intelligence.
How do you boost
your intelligence,
something that we also tend
to think of as rather fixed?
So that's the plan.
OK.
Let me start, then, by talking
about another day when reality
wasn't treating
me quite so well.
I was a bit further on in
my career as a management
consultant at this point.
I was a partner.
But even as a senior person
there, I still had to do things
I didn't enjoy.
And I'd been asked to join
this project that I was not
excited about.
It was a huge corporate
change program.
And by that time
in my life, I knew
that the kind of work that
I was most interested in
and that I most enjoyed
was more human-scale.
I liked working
with individuals,
coaching individuals,
and coaching teams.
So I was grumpy-- extra grumpy--
about being on this program.
And I was working
alongside a guy
who was kind of in the
opposite place-- he
was very excited about the
work-- a guy called Lucas.
Picture a tall, wiry,
well-dressed, highly energetic
German guy, very
good at process.
And he was all
over this project.
And this day that
I'm remembering
was the first day
that we were supposed
to be meeting our clients.
I was already grumpy
because I didn't
want to be on the project.
And then I was also
extra grumpy because we
were supposed to be
meeting the clients,
but it was a video conference.
I thought this was
a terrible idea.
We should be meeting
people in person
instead of being in
a video conference.
And then I was
even more dismayed
when I walked into
the room and saw
that it was a long, dark
room-- a little bit like this.
Less pleasant.
Lower ceilings.
Not as nice people in the room.
And there was a
screen in front of us.
And we were sitting
there disembodied,
faces floating in front of us.
This was our kickoff meeting.
And it was as bad
as I expected--
lots of misunderstandings,
miscommunications, people
cutting each other off, frowns.
It wasn't great.
So afterwards, I thought,
well, I'll be a good citizen.
I will sit down with Lucas.
And I will share my worries that
we've gotten off to a bad start
with the project.
And I can still picture
the conversation.
He was sitting there.
I was telling him all of these
things that had gone wrong.
He was looking at me as
if I was a little bit mad.
First of all, he hadn't
remembered the things
that I was talking about.
But then he went on to tell
me about all of these things
that I had not noticed.
People laughed several times.
People were really happy with
the progress that we made.
This deck that he was
powering through-- there
were lots of slides that
people had really loved.
I had no recollection of this.
And yet he was compelling
enough that I actually
realized on the edge
of my consciousness
he was not making this up.
So what was going on?
I mean, yes, we had different
personalities, of course.
But something else was going on.
It was as if we'd truly
been in a different meeting
from each other.
And of particular
interest to me--
why had he enjoyed himself
so much more than me?
And this is where it helps
to understand the brain.
Our brains are amazing.
They can do sums.
They can guess what
someone's thinking.
They can even tell jokes
if they're connected
to a big enough mouth.
But there are things
that they can't do.
And one thing that
they can't do is
they can't take in
everything that's around them
at any one time.
When you think about all of the
bits of information in a room,
if you really focused on
every fiber of the floor tiles
and you focused on every hair of
the person sitting next to you
and every sensation
in your body,
your brain would crash like
an overloaded computer.
So there's an elegant solution
that your brain employs,
which is to filter
out most of what's
going on around you
so that you're not
even conscious of it.
And as a result,
we're all experiencing
an edited, partial version
of reality all the time.
This is a little
bit mind-blowing,
because we don't
like to think of it.
We think of ourselves
as being objective.
But the reality that
we're experiencing
is not the same as
everyone else around us,
because their filters are
operating differently to yours.
And then the question is,
well, what determines what
you filter in and filter out?
And this is where the
big opportunity lies,
because it's quite predictable
what we tend to notice
and what we don't notice.
It turns out that whatever
is already top-of-mind
for us will determine
what our brain decides
is important enough for us to
consciously notice, whatever's
top-of-mind for us.
Let me give you an example of a
study that I like in this area.
It's a field called
selective attention,
the fact that we can
only pay attention
to a selection of
what's around us.
There were a bunch
of radiologists.
It was a Harvard study.
And they were given
a pile of lung scans
to look through-- sadly,
genuine lung scans.
And they're looking
for nodules, of course.
And the last of the
lung scans, there
was a gorilla printed
inside one of the lungs.
Now, how many of the
radiologists do you think
saw the gorilla?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
CAROLINE WEBB: So
it's close to that.
It's close to zero.
83% of the radiologists
did not see the gorilla,
even though eye-tracking
devices showed
that they looked directly at
it, even though the gorilla was
44 times the size of
the average lung nodule,
and even though they're
trained to spot abnormalities.
So why didn't they spot it?
Because gorillas were
not top-of-mind for them.
So that wasn't what
they were looking for.
And their brain completely
filtered it out.
Now, the massive
opportunity for us
is to be more
deliberate about what
we want to have top-of-mind
going into a day,
going into a meeting,
going into a task.
Because if we fall out
of bed on the wrong side
and we're grumpy, our brain
will say, OK, so you're grumpy.
That means that what's salient,
what's most relevant for you
to notice is everything
that confounds
the world is a terrible place.
So you'll spot the guy being
a jerk, the guy letting
the door slam in your face.
And you won't notice the
person holding it open.
You won't notice
the person who's
smiling at you in a
non-creepy way on the subway.
And we can turn
that around and say,
how about I decide to set
my aims and my attitude
and my assumptions in a
more positive direction?
And that will determine
where I put my attention.
And that's a little routine
I call setting intentions.
And I do it each day.
I do it sometimes
the night before.
I do it sometimes as I'm
hurdling into a meeting
and I've forgotten
to do it before.
And I say, Caroline, what
really matters to you?
What's, therefore,
your real aim?
Check in with your attitude
and your assumptions.
What does that mean you really
want to pay attention to?
And I've not had a
meeting quite like the one
I had with Lucas ever since.
Because even if the
meeting is going badly,
I can take a timeout quietly
halfway through and say, OK,
now what's my real aim?
What do I want to
have top-of-mind?
And it might be
to say, OK, I need
to learn from this experience.
And then I experience
the rest of the meeting
in a different way.
And I've even got
an emergency version
of this, which is when
I'm grumpy of a morning
and I'm walking along
and I say, OK, I'm
going to decide to notice three
good things in the next five
minutes.
The power of that is
that you notice things
you wouldn't have noticed.
Plus, then, because you've
got good things top-of-mind,
you notice more.
And that changes the
trajectory of the day.
So we can shape reality.
We can shape the reality
that we experience
really quite deeply and quite
powerfully and quite easily.
So that's the first thing that
behavioral science teaches us
that we have more control
over than we think.
Let me talk now about time.
Who here would like
more hours in a day?
Yes, of course.
Of course we would.
There are a couple
of ways that I know
of getting more hours in a day.
I like science fiction.
I watch a lot of
science fiction movies.
So I know that going to
the edge of a black hole
is, apparently, a great way of
getting more hours in a day.
Hard to fit that into
the average workday.
So let me talk about the second
technique, which you definitely
can fit in.
And to demonstrate
how this works,
I'm going to get you to
do a very small exercise.
I'm going to ask you, first
of all, to count to seven as
fast as you can out loud
with some energy on my mark,
like this.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Are you ready?
Go.
AUDIENCE: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Excellent.
Now I'm going to ask you to
do the same with letters.
I'm going to ask you to
say, a, b, c, d, e, f, g.
Again, energy.
On my mark.
Go.
AUDIENCE: A, b, c, d, e, f, g.
CAROLINE WEBB: Even sharper
and faster and more cultlike.
Excellent.
Now I'd like you
to mix the two up.
I'd like you to say, a, 1, b,
2, c, 3, again, as fast as you
can.
On my mark.
Go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLINE WEBB: I don't think
you-- you just gave up, right?
So I'm going to ask
some obvious questions.
I'm going to ask you, first
of all, which was quicker,
doing them on their own
or doing them mixed up?
AUDIENCE: On their own.
CAROLINE WEBB: On their own.
When did you make more mistakes,
doing them on their own
or mixed up?
AUDIENCE: Mixed up.
CAROLINE WEBB: Yes.
You've just, basically, revealed
many, many years of research
which suggests that
when we multitask,
we actually slow ourselves
down dramatically
and we make between two and
four times as many errors.
When we multitask, we make
ourselves a little bit dumber
and a little bit slower.
And yet that's how we
cope with our lives
where we have instant messages
coming at us all the time,
emails coming at
us all the time.
We're tempted by all
the wonderful websites
that are out there.
And then you're having
to get your work done.
You're talking to people.
We're trying to
process in parallel.
But our brain can actually
only do one thing consciously
at once.
It's a single-tasker.
Automatic stuff can
be done in parallel--
you know, brushing your teeth
while you're checking it.
That's OK.
But conscious tasks, you can
only do one thing at once.
So what your poor
brain is trying
to do when you're
checking your email
whilst you're getting on
with some task or other
is it's doing what you
were doing switching
between letters and numbers.
It's going from here
to here to here.
And in each of those switches,
you're losing a bit of time
and a bit of mental energy.
And that's why you
slow yourself down.
make more errors.
So we actually get our work
done more quickly and better
if we decide to
single-task, especially
around the tasks that
really matter to us,
where it really matters
for us to get it right.
And that means in our lives,
the kind of lives that we lead,
it means going offline
for periods of time.
And since this is
something which
I've been talking and writing
about for quite a long time,
I've developed a
raft of techniques
that I used for this when
I was in corporate life.
I was an avid user of
airplane mode on my phone,
very quickly flipping
that on whenever I really
needed to concentrate.
I had an enormous pair of
noise-canceling headphones
that I used to wear not just to
actually reduce ambient noise,
but also to try and
signal to my colleagues
that I was focusing to
the point where even when
the batteries ran
out, I would still
keep on wearing the headphones.
And I used to batch my
email as much as I could
so that I was blitzing it
two or three times a day,
rather than two or
three times a minute,
which meant that I was
getting through it more
quickly because I wasn't
switching all the time
from email to other things.
And then when I started
writing the book,
I had a lot less
structure in my life.
And I had to up my game, because
I was finding all sorts of ways
to get around
airplane mode and then
going to my browser
and start finding ways
to be distracted that way.
So I used apps to block
my access to social media
during working hours.
And in the end, I also
got myself a timer
to sit on my desk
which I would set
for a certain number of
minutes to stay focused,
to single-task.
And then it would
count down to zero.
And the reason that
it helped, apart
from giving me a point of
focus and promising myself
I didn't have to do it
for that much longer, was
that when it got to zero, I
got an approving little beep.
Beep.
Which was like a
pat on the back.
It made me feel good for having
been able to stay focused
for that length of time.
And that's helpful.
Because why do we stay online?
Because it's quite
nice to feel wanted
and to have the ping and
the buzz of the phone, like,
oh, somebody wants me.
So trying to give yourself a
pat on the back for actually
staying offline is
a very powerful way
of encouraging
yourself to do it more.
So single-tasking, you'll
make your time go further.
And it will make
you feel as if there
are more hours in the day.
Then let's talk about
your intelligence.
This is a very
intelligent room here.
Yes?
Yes.
You're all very modest.
But we know that we're
an intelligent room here.
But even you know
that there are days
when you're firing on all
cylinders and days when you're
not or days when the
tasks in front of you
seem a little bit harder.
Maybe it's something completely
new and you're a bit stuck.
Is there a way that
we can suddenly
become more intelligent?
Is there a way that we
can kind of suddenly
stick a second brain
onto our heads?
I'm going to tell
you about one day
that I learned a technique
which definitely does give you
a bit of a mental lift
when you most need it.
I was getting
certified as a coach.
I was doing this
course because I
worked a lot with
senior teams and boards
and I was often
finding myself getting
into one-to-one
conversations with people who
were asking me to help them.
And I thought,
wow, I really need
to make sure that
I've got the coaching
credentials to do this work.
So I went on this course.
And it was a very
bittersweet experience,
because I loved the course.
Shouldn't be a problem, right?
Except that I loved the
coaching so much, I thought,
oh, no, this is what I
have to do with my life.
I have to be a coach?
But I'm a partner at McKinsey.
And I quite like that.
I quite like my job.
I like my colleagues.
I like the sense of belonging.
I'm going to have to quit.
I didn't want to quit.
I was in this career dilemma
and worrying about it a lot.
And in a coaching
course when you're
learning to coach someone, the
way that you get your chops
is to actually
practice on each other
and really try to
learn by doing.
So there was one
day that someone
called Jill needed to practice
her coaching skills on me.
I needed to come up with a
real topic to be coached on.
This was the thing
that was on my mind.
So I said, OK,
bring it on, Jill.
Coach me.
She patiently did.
And she started by saying, OK,
so tell me what's going on.
And I told her that this
was a career dilemma,
and it couldn't be solved.
It was a disaster.
And I was going to have to quit.
And she said, OK, let's
just stop for a moment.
Caroline, what's the
ideal situation here?
And at first, I
was a bit grumpy,
because I said,
well, the ideal--
there's no point
talking about the ideal.
The ideal is that I'm
a coach at McKinsey.
But that's not possible.
So let's just move on, shall we?
She was very patient with me.
She then said,
OK, let's describe
that a little bit more, what
that would actually look like.
So I did that.
And then she said, now,
what would be the first step
towards that ideal?
And of course, the answer
was blindingly obvious.
It was, well, if I'm
going to leave anyway,
I've got nothing to lose.
I might as well
tell my colleagues
that this is something I want
to do more of, that I want to do
more coaching in the workplace.
Of course then
opportunities might arise.
And if they don't, I
can still leave, anyway.
And you're looking at
me like I'm an idiot.
Because of course that's
an obvious thing to do.
But it wasn't obvious
to me when I was stuck
in the mire of the problem.
Because I was so focusing
on the negative that
my brain was doing
something very specific.
It was going into
defensive mode.
So when we are facing
a threat in our lives,
our brain has a very
wonderful defensive mechanism
which has kept us safe for
millennia, which you might know
as a fight-or-flight response.
There's actually a third
response, which is to freeze.
So we might be snappish.
We might run away or hide.
We might actually
properly fight.
There might be real fisticuffs.
We might just keep our head down
and hope that nothing happens.
Fight, flight, freeze is
still our defensive response
to anything that
feels like a bit
of a threat in the workplace,
just as it was with charging
mammoths on the savanna.
And there are two things to know
about this defensive response.
The first is that it does
not take a charging mammoth
to trigger it, even
someone frowning at you.
Certainly, someone cutting
you off in a meeting.
Certainly a task that feels
just too difficult to solve.
These things will trigger
that defensive reaction.
And then the second thing
to know about defensive mode
is that when your brain
goes into defensive mode,
it's directing some
mental energy away
from the more sophisticated
part of your brain.
That means you can
see on a brain scan
that when people are
even mildly stressed,
that there's less activity
in their prefrontal cortex.
So here's the rub.
You're faced with a
challenging situation
just at that moment when
you need to rise to it.
You become slightly less sharp,
slightly less intelligent.
So what Jill did
was very clever,
because she was lifting me
out of this defensive mode
by asking me a question, which
got me to focus on something
which was far more positive.
What's the ideal situation?
And what's the first
step towards that?
It was very rewarding
to think about the ideal
and then also to
think about a step
that I could actually take.
It boosted my sense
of competence.
Bam, I'm out of defensive
mode and thinking
more clearly and creatively.
And you see this
time and time again
in meetings where people
are getting bogged down
to ask a question like
that to pull people out
of defensive mode and get
them refocused on what
the ideal might be and what
a step towards that might be
or to say, when have we solved
a problem like this before?
And what can we learn from that?
It's a way of giving yourself
a few extra IQ points on days
when you might be
struggling a little bit
or when you're facing problems
that seem insurmountable.
So to recap, by
setting your intentions
clearly and positively,
you can shape the way
that you experience reality.
Second, by single-tasking
as much as you can,
and especially in the work
that really matters to you,
you can steal back
more time in the day.
And you can give yourself
a boost in intelligence
and in mood by using positive
task framing, asking yourself,
what's the ideal and what's
the first step towards that?
And these are just three
tiny, tiny, tiny little steps
that emerged from the
behavioral science that
can have enormous impacts on
the way that every day feels.
And more enjoyable
reality, more time,
and more intelligence-- that has
to be a recipe for a good day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANANT SHUKLA: So we have
some mics set up here
for Q&A. Feel free to jump up.
I have a few questions
for you myself, Caroline.
CAROLINE WEBB: Ah-ha.
And he's read the book.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah, I've
read the book, as well.
So I recommend it
to all of you guys.
We were chatting a little
bit about this before.
I know you mentioned it took
four years almost to write
the book, a little over four.
What for you was most
challenging and rewarding
coming out of this experience of
taking the best of what you've
learned in your
professional life,
reading the research
studies to come up
with these clear insights
that are actionable
for everybody here, and to
really have that better day?
CAROLINE WEBB: I would
say that it's the hardest
thing that I've ever done.
But it's the most
rewarding thing.
To take stock of everything that
you've done over the last 20
years professionally and say,
what's the essence of this
and how can I share this?
It's quite a privilege.
And I never lost sight
of that, even when I
was feeling very lonely.
Because it's a very solitary
experience to write a book.
And I think that was the
most difficult thing.
I was so used to doing
this work with people
that, inevitably at some points,
you have to actually say,
no, my job now is
actually writing the book.
There's a great management
thinker, Lynda Gratton,
who told me this very
early on in the process.
She said, at some
point, you have
to accept that your job
is writing this book.
And so yes, that
period where I didn't
get the chance to actually
still be working with people.
But it's been worth it.
It's been worth it.
Because now I get to go
back out into the world
and talk to wonderful
people, like you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Awesome.
I know throughout the
book, as well, you
mention sleep, which didn't
come up in any of the stories
you mentioned today.
And everybody here at work
in our professional lives,
in our personal lives,
sleep and physical activity
are two of the first
things we let slip by.
And you've shown in
countless studies
that you've researched, your own
experience, whether it drives
fight-or-flight,
whether it drives
the unpleasant meeting that
we're having, it's something we
let go.
So what are your few tips to
squeeze into an extra half
hour or an hour that will really
then make that difference?
And I think maybe
share with the audience
some of those kind of
findings that have come out.
CAROLINE WEBB: We
all know on one level
that the way we treat our body
affects the way our mind works.
We know that when
we're under-slept,
we become somehow less
witty and charming.
But we often behave as if
the connection isn't direct.
We might accept that there's
a long-term connection.
But actually, the research
is really compelling.
It says that the way
that you treat your body
has an immediate effect
on your mental state.
So the research on
exercise is fantastically
encouraging for
someone like me, who
does not like going to the gym.
I did a lot of sport when
I was younger as a kid.
And then it's hard to fit
team sports into adult life.
And so I always struggled
with getting enough exercise
into my day.
I was personally very
encouraged by the research,
which says in terms
of the benefits
to your cognitive state,
doing more exercise boosts
your emotional resilience.
And it makes you
sharper and more focused
and more analytically
smart-- immediately.
Goodness.
OK.
You can get that after 20
minutes of moderate exercise.
I thought, OK, 20 minutes
moderate exercise.
That's a brisk walk.
I can do that.
I started walking a lot more.
And I was even more encouraged
with more research that's
been coming out in
the last year or two
which suggests that it's
not even just 20 minutes.
You can break it down into
chunks of 5 or 10 minutes.
There was one study that I
read that said, obviously,
more exercise might
be better than some,
but some is better than none.
And I took that to heart.
So I walk a lot more.
I seize every opportunity.
So we know that on one
level, that's a good thing.
But actually, just to
know that it's immediately
going to improve your
mood and your focus,
that helps you put the time in.
And then with sleep,
yeah, it's interesting.
Actually, I spoke at Google in
London a couple of weeks ago.
And someone came
up to me afterwards
and said, if there's
one thing out of all
of this physical stuff
that you're talking about
that I should be looking
after, what is it?
And I said, well, it is sleep.
There's definitely
very clear research.
You've probably heard about
this, that going short of sleep
is equivalent to
having a few drinks.
And you wouldn't say that
someone at work who was short
of sleep was an excellent
worker if they were drunk.
But we have a slightly macho
approach to saying, you know,
yeah, I only got four
hours last night.
I'm working really hard.
The truth is that-- again,
all the evidence suggests--
that you have less
memory of what you did
and you learn less
from what you're
doing if you go short on sleep.
So all of that, yes.
So what do you then do?
I think some of it is just
about an attitude and a mindset
and not seeing
sleep as a luxury,
not seeing sleep as
downtime, but seeing it
as essential up-time.
It's when your brain is doing
encoding and consolidation.
And that subtle
shift into saying
that this is actually going to
make me smarter when I wake up
tomorrow morning, I think
that's been very helpful for me.
That, and recognizing
that when you
have a lot of light around
you-- and particularly lights
from your devices-- it's going
to delay your sleep cycle.
So there's research
at Harvard that's
more recent than some
of the sleep research
saying that we push our
rhythms back by half an hour
for every half an hour that
we're sitting with our phone
late at night.
So there's something
about sleep hygiene
and just making sure that your
room is actually dark enough.
And that really helps, too.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
In another chapter, I
think you mentioned--
the whole chapter is about
managing relationships.
And there are a few pages that
have common defensive mode
triggers that you might
elicit in a person you're
engaging with.
So can you touch upon
a little bit in some
of these tense situations
where you don't necessarily
have the time to maybe
diagnose the situation
or identify the
telltale sign-- how
would you react accordingly?
How can we, again,
implement those types
of things on a quick notice?
And maybe even outline
for the audience
what those common defensive
triggers might be.
CAROLINE WEBB: So what
Anant is talking about
is that you know when someone
is behaving dysfunctionally.
And you've got this
split-second decision
where you can kind of
declare that they're a jerk,
or you can decide that there
might be something going on
with them.
And there's something
in psychology
which is called the
fundamental attribution error.
And the way it works
is that if we show up
and we're a bit
cranky at work, we
know it's because we
didn't get enough sleep.
But if someone else
is cranky, then we
have a tendency to decide that
they're a terrible person.
Because why?
Because your brain is always
trying to take shortcuts.
And it's a lot simpler to just
declare that this person is not
that nice, versus
thinking about, well,
what could be
going on with them?
It's just simpler to just
badge them in a certain way.
So one of the things
that you can do
is just get yourself familiar
with the common triggers that
might be causing--
apart from lack
of sleep-- dysfunctional
behavior that might be putting
someone into defensive mode.
So there are individual ones,
like competence, autonomy,
and security.
Anything that undermines
someone's sense of competence,
their autonomy, their
sense of security
will put them into
defensive mode
and make them behave badly.
Then there are social needs,
like belonging and fairness
and respect.
And as soon as any of
those are violated at all,
then you have a situation where,
again, that defensive mode
is going to be triggered.
So it helps to just
know the territory
and just to get into
the habit of saying,
OK, this is probably
not a psychopath.
This is probably--
just statistically,
it's unlikely that
they're a psychopath.
They're probably what
I call a good person
in bad circumstances.
What are the circumstances?
You tell yourself a few
stories around those themes.
Or it could be something
even more basic,
like their cat died, right?
That's not even on the list.
That's just something
that makes you sad.
So just stopping and
giving yourself that pause
and saying, what could
be going on with them,
changes your demeanor
towards them,
which de-escalates
the situation.
Because you are not then putting
them further on the defensive.
And that is a great first step.
And then there's a whole
bunch of other things
that you can do, like showing
appreciation-- fantastic silver
bullet.
It hits competence,
security, belonging.
It makes for a quick way of
getting the other person out
of defensive mode.
Should we ask the audience
for some questions?
Yes.
ANANT SHUKLA: Do you want
to step up to the mic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So your discussion about
multitasking and productivity
was really interesting.
A lot of people that
I've met, I feel,
want to believe that they have
some special ability to just--
they can juggle whatever
and check their email.
And I'm just wondering if the
research that you saw really
showed a gradient from
what people can handle
and different people's
abilities, versus-- you're
probably the best
person qualified
to answer this question.
So I might as well ask you.
CAROLINE WEBB: Thank you
very much for asking.
Yeah.
So one of the reasons that we
tend to think we can multitask
is that there are certain things
we can multitask with, right?
So if it's an automatic
task, the automatic system
in our brain generally can do
multiple things in parallel.
So that's why you can find your
way to work without necessarily
concentrating on
where you're going
while you're doing
something else,
maybe checking your messages.
It's why when you're
driving, it might be possible
for you to have a
conversation with someone.
But the moment that anything
changes in the situation--
perhaps you're driving
along and a car pulls out--
and it requires conscious
attention from you,
then you're back in
the mode of only being
able to do one thing at a time.
And that's why so many crashes
happen when people are talking.
Because it feels as if
it's possible to do things
in parallel.
And then something changes,
requires conscious attention.
So I think that's
one of the reasons we
tend to believe that we
can with conscious tasks,
as well as with
unconscious tasks.
But there's really
interesting research
out there showing
that people who
are most confident of
their ability to multitask
are actually the worst at it.
And why might that be?
It might be that
they've lost the ability
to be mentally agile, because
they're just totally bombarded
all the time.
It's really interesting.
And I think, also,
the trope that's
been out there for a
long time that women
can somehow multitask, right?
For the women in the
audience, don't believe it.
When it comes to the kind of
conscious work that we're doing
at work, we really can't.
We're no different from men.
So just to lay
that one out there.
Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
This is really interesting.
Did you find that
your techniques
for having a good day and
turning a bad day into a better
day changed when you started
working at home and away
from other people with less
things to influence you
and less things
to notice that you
could frame in positive ways?
CAROLINE WEBB: That's a
good, interesting question.
I've had quite a few different
types of work and career
in my life.
And I definitely think that when
you move into a new setting,
you don't have to take
a step back and say, OK,
some of the things that I
did before-- it is different.
The multitasking example
was so vivid to me.
I thought I really nailed this.
And then, actually,
oh, my goodness.
I really haven't because of
the change in circumstances.
So I guess what I would
advocate is just checking in
with yourself and
developing a self-awareness
so that you maybe
take the principles.
The stuff in the
book I've seen work
across lots of
different settings
and lots of different
industries and roles.
And the stories in
the book reflect that.
So I've tried to
create a manual that
can sort of apply to all
sorts of different settings.
But the way that it translates
into your own life, yeah,
you need to experiment
with that, for sure,
especially around
times of change.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is fantastic.
And I think it's--
certainly as, hopefully,
high-functioning adults, we
can take some of this to heart.
I'm wondering if you have any,
well, A, if there's research,
or, B, if you have any
recommendations for how
you would coach children
to implement some of this.
CAROLINE WEBB: Well, I have
to say that most of my clients
have children.
And most of them tell me that
they practice on their children
before they practice
on their colleagues.
I hear a lot about
teenage children.
spouses, actually.
I've had a lot of people
tell me that the techniques
have improved their marriage.
I actually even had
one of my clients
tell me about how he had
used some of the techniques
from the relationship
part of the book
with his one-year-old son.
So they were worried
that their son
was slow in starting
to pick up language.
And his wife was
particularly concerned
that Francesca wasn't
speaking enough to the child.
And so Francesca, having fresh
from reading all the stuff
on relationships and rapport
and the power of actually truly,
deeply listening and
paying close attention
and playing back
what you're hearing,
decided to do that
with his young son.
And so instead of
just talking at him,
he would listen so what
the little one was saying
and then repeat it back and then
add in one or two extra words.
And his language
acquisition skills
went off the chart so quickly.
Because even at
that young age, all
of the things that we're talking
about in terms of competence,
autonomy, security,
belonging, fairness respect,
these things kick in very early.
So I would say that all of the
techniques, as far as I know,
can be tried with children.
And I'd love to hear if
you'd like to give it a go.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
The tip that you gave
about using a timer
sounds fascinating.
I'm wondering if there's
an ideal amount of time
that we can focus.
CAROLINE WEBB: Yeah.
That's a good question.
There are lots of
different views on this.
You've got people who swear by
the Pomodoro Technique, which
is the 25 minutes.
There are some people
who say 90 minutes is
optimal for really deep work.
I guess it goes back to the
earlier point-- you do need
to experiment.
I'll be honest.
When I came out
of corporate life,
I had to start
with five minutes.
I had to retrain myself.
And I started with five.
And then I went up to 10.
And eventually, I
went around to 90.
And then for me, I ended up
putting it back to 45 minutes.
Because I found that I would
find it quite easy-- not easy.
But I mean, it became second
nature to focus for 45 minutes.
If I was really
engaged in a task,
then I'd go past the 45 minutes.
And I'd feel really good.
If I set it at 60
or 75 or 90 and then
I kind of lost
focus before then,
it would set up a dynamic where
I'd be slightly disappointed
with myself.
And I discovered it was
a much better dynamic
to set it for a
shorter amount of time,
and I'd feel really
great about myself
and then be more
inclined to try it again.
So I would start
small and build up.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
So set really low
expectations for yourself.
CAROLINE WEBB:
[LAUGHS] Yes, yes.
Yes.
I probably shouldn't admit
the five-minute thing.
But I just did.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
worry about realistic optimism
or positivism
delaying change that
could help you in your life?
CAROLINE WEBB: Yeah.
Sometimes people say,
well, sometimes you just
need to quit your job, actually.
You're just not in
the right place.
You're not in the right fit.
I think that sometimes you
do need to make big changes.
And the one thing I
would say is that I
think that focusing
on the day-to-day,
focusing on improving the
small steps in your life
puts you in a better position
to make the big decisions.
If you're thinking about
making a career move,
it's much more
likely that you'll
make good choices if
you're not doing it
from a place of desperation.
So the more that you can
improve the day-to-day, I think,
the more that you'll, obviously,
enjoy the journey a bit more,
but you'll also probably
choose the destination
more effectively.
ANANT SHUKLA: Do we have
any more audience questions?
AUDIENCE: This is
actually just more
of a comment about
the multitasking.
My 86-year-old mother-in-law
claims that she can.
And there's no
arguing that point.
So where it became
really obvious to me
about the automatic and
how when the automatic
is no longer automatic-- it
really changes everything.
I had a foot problem,
which was very painful
under the ball of my left foot.
Every single step I took with my
left foot I had to think about.
And if you don't think
your world doesn't
change when you have
to think about walking,
it's pretty incredible.
And I would even
actually on the weekends
not do things because
the sheer energy
of having to walk to lower
Manhattan or do something
actually would
prevent me from doing
that because of all the thinking
involved-- not the pain.
I'm living with that.
But it's the thinking
about the walking.
CAROLINE WEBB: Absolutely.
Beautiful example.
Our brain's working memory
has such a small capacity
that even a blinking light or a
buzzing phone or something that
is as simple as walking can
take part of your brain's
mental energy and make it hard
to think about anything else.
Really nice example.
Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Cool.
Well, hopefully everybody's
got a few insights and tips now
that they can take away.
Let's give another round
of applause to Caroline.
CAROLINE WEBB: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]